but instead of looking at values of this
guy
i'm looking at the same points and i'm
looking at the values of
this guy and you can quickly just
substitute some in just to prove to
yourself my numbers are not made up
if you put in x equals 1 x equals 1 you
get 6
times 1 minus 12 which is negative 6 and
you can see
my negative 6 right there does that make
sense
ok all right so this is what the second
derivative
looks like but what does it tell us
first derivative tells us are you
increasing or decreasing
or stationary what does this
tell us what are you thinking so it's
the rate of change of the actual rate of
change
basically it's a straight line
yeah this is a straight line this is a
linear function isn't it in fact if i
graphed it it looks something like
it goes straight through here is where
it would pass through okay
were you going to say something similar
or different but then i tell you like
after like
the stationary point where the graph
goes positive or negative hmm
can you say that again after the
stationary point
it tells you what up or down whether the
graph goes up or down okay so
i'm interested in unpacking what you
mean maybe and this
actually would be helpful to put onto
your graph right go ahead take these
numbers
pop them on to roughly where they should
belong onto yours i'm going to highlight
just like i did with the first
derivative
the places where our graph has a
negative second derivative and the place
where it has a positive second
derivative so let me show you those bits
here's the parts where the second
derivative is
negative
and then here's the ones where it's
positive i want you to keep thinking
with me okay sorry that's so messy but
you get the idea
okay what's going on
okay so so there's a few thoughts going
around the first thing i hear is there's
a lot of symmetry here
just like with the previous ones
remember that okay there's a lot of
symmetry you can see the values
okay well what are you thinking the
numbers are changing on the y-axis
relative to the x-axis the bigger the
numbers are
if that makes sense the faster the
numbers are changing
on the y-axis the bigger the numbers are
on on these ones that i've written the
second derivative okay now
let me just say it one more time and i'm
just going to as i say it and shane baby
i'll come to you next
i want you to look at what we've written
here right what we're suggesting is
the faster there's change happening here
right the bigger these numbers seem to
be do you agree with that
hmm
shane barber did you have a different
thought or a similar one
ah so you're about about five minutes
ahead of me
i will come to you though okay it's fine
it's fine we are gonna go there okay
let me explain what's going on because
we could we could workshop this idea for
a while right but
telling you if it grabs maximum or
aluminum
yes but that's not quite it's not quite
what i'm going to okay
all right have a look with me have a
look with me okay i'm going to return to
will's point right
have a look here what's happening the
answer is your function is doing what
it's increasing right you see it's going
up
it's going up but but it's slowing down
do you see that
it's still increasing but it's
increasing at a slower and slower pace
until
this point right here you see that point
am i increasing or decreasing at this
point
at this point right here increasing
you're increasing i'm gonna say it one
more time am i increasing or decreasing
at this exact point
the answer is i'm stationary you saw
that on the first derivative right
it's a stationary point
because this is the second derivative
right now look right
at this point i now start decreasing
why is that and the answer is because
how's the rate of change
changing the rate of change is zero at
this moment but it's it's about to come
down
the rate of change is decreasing the
rate of change is decreasing here we say
that again the rate of change is
decreasing the rate of change is
decreasing here
the rate of change is still decreasing
that's why you turn around
does that make sense i'm going to say
one more time right
at this point here which is the one i
started with the function's increasing
yeah it's going up but your rate of
change
is decreasing the whole function slowing
down as it approaches this point
it has to slow down because it's going
to become stationary that's what
stationary means you stop moving
right okay now what about this point
here
here's what i'm really interested in
right you can see it switches over from
blue
to red my rate of change
stops changing at this point which is
why if you zoomed in really hard
like that okay if i zoom in like that
and this is the only part of the graph
that you can see
this graph doesn't look like a curve
anymore does it
do you notice this part of graph just
looks like a straight line
it looks like it's not changing at all
at that one little moment
okay but then when i come back out
what's going on
well the rate of change is now saying
hey i want you to go up this way now if
you can imagine someone sort of like
pulling this thing up dragging it
upwards
and so it's like oh fine okay okay i'll
turn around and off it goes
gets the stationary point to minimum as
you can see and it heads up
now the language that we use to describe
this geometrically is actually what
chamber avi was getting to
right what you could say what you could
summarize this is saying is
this blue part of the graph it has a um
it has a concavity we talk about this
word concavity we'll talk about
parabolas
right we talk about a concave up
parabola or a concave
down parabola see the blue part it's
concave
down you see it's facing downwards um if
that was a cup
right it'd be turned upside down the
water's all fallen out right by contrast
this guy here is concave
up if you put water in it would hold it
up okay it would stay there
so we now can come back to what we've
written here right first derivative
secondary move what does each one tell
us
the first derivative is the rate of
change right so this is about gradient
are you going up or are you going down
the second derivative is this where the
shambhava is talking about it's
concavity
are you are you going up and going down
but are you doing it faster or slower
right are you um are you slowing down as
you approach a stationary point or are
you like
getting faster and faster or even going
off in this direction
okay and this is a big new idea we're
going to spend some time dwelling on it
today and next week as well you're ready
to make the heading now which is
the second derivative and concavity
these are the two
concepts we're exploring today
the second derivative
and
concavity okay now i
have just enough space over here on this
side i'll write the questions on the
exercise shortly but
um seren kind of um anticipated this we
need to know how to write this i don't
really want to write second derivative
equals every single time
we have shorthand for writing everything
right so i'm going to introduce some
language that helps you with this
okay so if your function
is why then we already know how to write
the first derivative
first derivative um
i'm going to use this notation here that
i that we've been using for a while now
dy and dx
okay if by contrast the function was
written as f of x
then we would write its derivatives f
dash x right
okay so now i'm going to tell you show
you how do we write the next derivative
now it just so happens that actually
starting with this function notation
is easier see that dash that dash means
hey that thing
differentiate it right so how did we get
to the second derivative what did we do
we differentiated another time right so
they're like well if the first one was f
dash the next one is f dash dash
it's another dash because dash means
differentiate it again
if i could do f dash dash dash if i
wanted you know you can differentiate as
many times as you like
x okay now when it comes to this one
right
i'm going to write it but it's going to
look weird and i'm going to explain why
it looks weird in a second okay
we know it's going to look like a
fraction like this but what does this
process
look like when you differentiate it
again
um you don't need to write this bit you
don't need to write this bit but i do
want you to see it so maybe actually
pins
out of hands for a second i want you to
watch right um
d y on dx i can write that as
d on dx of y do you know when d on dx is
what we call the differential operator
it means hey the thing you're about to
see differentiate that thing
right but we kind of like shorthand
write that y up the top that's why the y
sort of sneaks up there
okay now what is the second derivative
it's you you take this thing and then
you differentiate that
so it's not d on dx of y
it's d and dx of of that thing right
hmm how can we like
combine that together in a neater
looking way
have a look at the numerator you see how
there's
d and then there's d again so we have
shorthand for that right we're like you
did it twice
so i'm going to write that as d squared
right you take the difference twice okay
and then and then there's that y hanging
out on the bottom
okay now have a look at the um have a
look at the denominator
have a look at the denominator what do
you see on the denominator
there's two dx's now if i wanted to be
like
if i wanted to be really pedantically
correct what i would write is
see that dx thing that happens twice so
i square it
but there's this funny interplay between
you know how i keep saying we've said it
many times mathematicians
famously lazy right they're so lazy that
in a
rare moment of laziness overcoming
technical accuracy
instead of writing the second derivative
like so they write it as
d squared y over you can write this in
your little
table now d x squared without the
brackets
okay but what they really mean is you do
that dx thing you do it
twice because you differentiated twice
to get there
okay so this here is the notation oh
sorry wrong color
this is the notation that we're going to
use to indicate the function
and whatever derivative it is that
you're working with
okay